so there was a UFO to hear uh UFO
hearing today and I got to tell you it
was one of the most boring things I've
had to listen to when I had a playing in
the background and eventually I just
turned it off but there were some things
that I found interesting the first thing
I'll say is I don't believe any of it I
think I don't trust these individuals
they're testifying I think uh they're
misleading people and uh factual but not
truthful in how they describe things
let me just say
Hunter Biden was facing a plea agreement
it fell apart the judge threw that there
seems to be some very serious back room
dealing going on that they could not say
on paper or in court and the judge kind
of figured it out and everything's
falling apart and then surprise surprise
a UFO hearing happens where some guy
says that non-human biologics have been
recovered from off-earth technology I'm
not going to bury the lead
a a weather balloon with a cat in it is
off-earth technology piloted by a
non-human entity okay